so who's thirsty the waters of Mars this
oh boy this one was interesting and also
this review is brought to you by radio
versus the Martians it's a podcast which
means you have to pay anything for it
and it features Mike Gillis and Casey
Doran as well as a performing staple of
yes and they talk about all manner of
geeky stuff anime wrestling Batman
vigilante films Star Wars Star Trek
whatever is on their minds and of course
that does include podcasts LaVista baby
every single movie that I love sports
any girl has ever made radio versus the
Martians at Radio versus the Martians
calm or wherever you get your podcast
this was a weird one to go back to I've
always had a bit of an odd relationship
with waters of Mars I've never disliked
it and never thought it was bad but the
thing is I think at this point I have a
reputation for fame for for not liking
it because it's an episode that tends to
show up on a lot of people's top 10
lists or otherwise praising of Doctor
Who in general or a tenant's era or
Russell T Davies
writing in particular and I think the
only time that ever cracked my top 10
was when I did one on scariest episodes
and even then I still had some caveats
so there's this perception I think that
I hate this episode because I don't
lionize it the way a lot of other people
seem to I do like this episode I've
always liked this episode and having
rewatched it now I've realized we're a
bit of the disconnect was and I've come
to appreciate it more here was the odd
thing that I realized after watching it
and thinking about it for a bit because
basically everything got it came to
gather as it closed then I had to think
okay why is this working for me here
where it didn't before or at least
didn't as well and the thing was what
most people like go nuts about when
talking about this episode at least so
far as what I've seen them go nuts about
are how scary it is you know the tension
the how horrifying the flood is and the
thing is those have never really quite
rang true to me but what I realized
after watching it this time is this is a
great episode but the reason I think
it's great
aren't the reasons everyone else has
been telling me that it's great and I
think that's why I kind of pushed back a
little because people were like well all
these things that I'm looking at those
going but those aren't working for me on
the same level so the episode might must
not be that good no it's very very good
just for me at least for different
reasons cuz I don't think this is
particularly scary
I get why for some people it is but I
don't find it very scary at all it's
nowhere near as scary as blink as the
empty child as the bastion of errata
are it's I don't find it as scary as the
silence nowhere near as scary as the
midnight entity I mean I again I get why
it is for some people but for me it just
isn't really man that looks kind of cool
but they're zombies and I know zombies I
know zombies like the back of my
recently bitten hand I should get that
checked out um if I was smart I would
have done up like makeup or something on
that to actually sell that joke but I'm
lazy plus I thought of it off the top my
head good I don't script a lot of the
time oh I'm giving away everything here
anyways because they are such a zombie
analog with infected water subbing in
for what would otherwise be infected
blood that you know I'm like I've kind
of seen this it's a variant it's an
interesting variant but like I've seen
it and a big part of anything that
scares me is when I don't is if I feel
off put I'm like I don't entirely know
what's going on and that's never really
been the case here
actually I would argue I don't think the
episode itself is even trying to be as
scary as a lot of people claim that it
is because there's only a couple of jump
scares and it's really only the first
two times that we see someone infected
by the flood that it's played off as
legitimately scary and after that when
people get infected it's not played as
scary it's played as tragic as played as
inevitable which it is because within
what like 15 minutes of this episode of
starting the doctor realizes and the
audience does as well these people are
all gonna die so there's no real tension
in wondering will they get out of this
and honestly that's something I've
criticized about this before so like to
compare to the Vashta Nerada one of the
reasons that I'm like I don't find the
flood as scary as this this idea that
even the slightest touch of the water
will infect you it's a certainty and I
find way less fear in anything that's
certain it's the uncertainty that scares
me so the idea of save the Vashta Nerada
where not every shadow but any shadow
that is way scarier to me then all water
is infected if you touch it you're
you're doomed and you add into that fact
that we know that these people are going
to die and so again it becomes a
certainty so there's no that there's
none of the tension of oh maybe maybe I
don't know we know and I think before
I've been looking at through the lens of
well that makes it less scary but I
don't think the goal of the episode is
actually to be scary not that it's not
that it's like not hoping to be scary
but I think that's the function or the
goal of the episode overall so when so
much praise focuses on how scary it is
and for me I just find it to not be I
tend to go well it doesn't work very
well but there's a lot here that does
work
there's a lot here that is very well
done and makes the entire thing well
worth a you know making and viewing that
has nothing to do with it being scary so
like I said whenever someone gets
infected it's played as tragic I mean I
think the best example to give it
happens with most of them after the
first couple get infected
it's a Stephie and she is she's trapped
in this room she can't leave it cuz the
like the water is pouring down in front
of the doorway and the water starts
coming in and she turns and you know
watches the monitor with her family on
it and then the water starts to rain on
to her and she's crying and the music is
not high tension it's not doom and gloom
it's not pretentious it's slow and it's
sad because the tragedy is that these
people are going to die no matter what
the doctor knows that and he's resigned
himself to that he even makes and they
kind of needed to coming off series for
the comparison to Pompeii that these
people it because Pompeii you like and
everyone in the city died he could save
a few he could save a family but here's
like all these specific individual
people it's important historically that
they die and the doctor knows and
believes for the majority of the film
that he can't help and then he does and
initially when that and I say initially
I don't mean like first time I watched
it I mean this time watching him when he
has that turn to be like you know the
Time Lords used to enforce the rules but
they're gone so I get to make the rules
I was like this the here it is the
arrogance and and the self-importance
and which again is not bad as a
character trait it's it
I mean it's his fatal flaw in many ways
and there's nothing wrong with the lead
character the fatal flaw but like the
music kicks in with I think it's it's
the sort of the the known bit from all
the strange strange creatures you know
very triumphant he's coming back he's
like yes
the doctor is gonna save gonna run like
why is this being played off his
triumphant when it's like this is a
horrible idea but it's because the
things on a slower burned than that and
it's not till you get to the end and he
has his conversation with the captain
because it's not the fact that she kills
himself as himself she kills herself
it's that conversation she has with him
that makes it clear why this is not okay
because that's the thing that if this
episode is gonna do this it really has
to drive home why this was not okay
because on paper the doctors right
history will more or less sort itself
out things the correct events will still
occur just a few different details it's
fine he can do this it's fine and in
terms of the specific event that's true
but that's now instilled in him a sense
of superiority that is not safe for
someone with his degree of power to have
he shouldn't feel superior to the other
beings in the universe because if he
does if he feels like the rules don't
apply to him no matter what his
intentions are he's going to become a
monster and part of me kind of wishes
that coming off of this sort of like in
the Time Lord triumphant the time Time
Lord victorious mode if we got in a
story after that of him just riding the
high of the air against it was probably
good idea not to do that before bringing
him down a peg because it might have
damaged the character just irreparably
part of me still feels that that's a
little bit of a lost storytelling
opportune
but that conversation that the two of
them have and her saying flat out this
is wrong and his response is to just
look at her and go tough
he doesn't care anymore and the only
thing that she can do in utter defiance
of him because the entire point that he
decided to make was I'm going to save
you and she decided no no you're not and
the point is and and like at least the
point as I took it it's not that she has
to die for history to be correct that's
not it she's not doing this to save
preserve time or history because like
it's already changed she was supposed to
die on Mars now she dies on earth she's
doing it to show him the lengths that
people are going to have to go to in
order to stop what he's doing and she
kills herself and that snaps him out of
it he realized whoa okay holy crap I did
something with good intent but I did
something that puts someone in a
situation where they believed it was so
important to define me that they killed
himself not to kill themself to prevent
or cause a specific thing but just to
define me because that's the only thing
they could do in the face of what I have
become Wow okay and he breaks out a bit
and rightfully so some of the times when
the 10th doctor breaks down towards the
end of his run I'm a little iffy on this
one nope nope that feels earned because
he was riding a truck what had been a
triumph and it just got smacked out from
under him and this time watching it and
it's not like I didn't appreciate all of
this stuff before but for some reason
I had before watching this that had
always been part of the wrap-up you know
that's part of how it ties in to the
next story but I'd always kind of framed
it through the well you know it's
telling the scary story that does
there's other stuff but it's not telling
scoot stick a scary story what it's
telling is a story specifically designed
to spur this doctor down a path that he
should not travel and make him do it and
believe he is righteous and then smack
him upside the head for having the
hubris to think that that was okay in
some ways I wonder if this story was
reverse engineered from where the doctor
had to end up by the end to come up with
what story would drive him to that point
I don't know if that's how Russell T
Davies approached it maybe it is I mean
I know there's like a book of him you
know that that records a lot of his
thoughts and writings on this so maybe
I'm completely off-base but it does feel
properly built it's not a tacked on
oh how do we connect to the next thing
that I used to feel it was it does all
build to that and if it scares you along
the way
it probably adds to the effectiveness of
it it doesn't scare me it never has but
for what it's actually setting out to do
it doesn't need to scare me and I
haven't even really talked about the
performances the music the makeup effect
to which as I said it doesn't scare me
but it's very cool and Lindsay Duncan is
phenomenal and the rest of the
supporting cast is pretty good too not
quite at the level of say the impossible
planet Saint Pitt that's still my top
four like we we encounter a group of
folks in a Space Station situation and
inve of an established dynamic they're
not quite at that level but it's it's in
the ballpark and yeah
all the other stuff is good but I wanted
to talk narrative structure and theming
and build and what it's actually doing
because I'm still gonna push back
people tell me that this episode is
super scary or that it's good because
it's scary cuz it's not it's good
because it earns the very extreme place
that the doctor goes to and the very
extreme lengths that another character
goes to to snap him out of it it's great
because it earns that not because it's
scary which again for me it isn't but
this has been a really fascinating
rewatch it might be the one that has
gone up the most in my assessment versus
the last time I've seen it that said it
still might not crack haha a top ten for
me we'll see but you know just fair
warning waters of Mars you seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it there's
also a link to my patreon down there
helps cover my bills and it's greatly
appreciated but you know there's other
stuff down there where the down there as
well there's my socials and link to my
book and all sorts of stuff click on
things check them out you also don't
have to cuz at the end of the day folks
you're the council just run in the
meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]